TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION TODAY
IS JANUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY WE HAVE A TOTAL OF FIVE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA AND TOOL OF
WHICH ARE ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA IS GONNA
BE JOINING US LATER HE'S GONNA
BE SUBBING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL SINCE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM WE COULD PROCEED AS A-
SUBCOMMITTEE SINCE I HAVE A
BILL SO I. VAST VICE CHAIR TO
CHAIR THE MEETING WHILE I
PRESENT MY BILL IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH YOU. THIS IS. THANK YOU
SIR. HARRY. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I LIKE TO
START OFF BY A- AGREEING TO THE
AMENDMENTS LISTED ON PAGE SEVEN
OF THE ANALYSIS TO ADDRESS THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS OF THE
AMENDMENTS WILL ESSENTIALLY AND
SURE THAT THE BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO EXPAND THE
AUTHORITY OF A GOVERNMENT
ENTITY TO USE SOFTWARE FOR
SURVEILLANCE OF THIS BILL AB
NINE OH FOUR AS CURRENTLY
IMPRINTS SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT ENTITIES CANNOT USE
TRACKING SOFTWARE. THAT PERMITS
THE TRACKING OF THE MOVE
MOVEMENT OF A PERSON OR OBJECT
WITHOUT A WARRANT. A CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES A SEARCH WARRANT
BE ISSUED BEFORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER CAN INSTALL
A TRACKING DEVICE OR SERVING A
WARRANT. ON A THIRD PARTY
POSSESSOR OFF THE TRACKING DATA
HOWEVER WITH NEW TECHNOLOGY IT
IS NO LONGER NECESSARY FOR THE
OFFICER TO MAKE PHYSICAL
CONTACT WITH A DEVICE. PERSON
OR VEHICLE TO INSTALL A DEVICE
IN ORDER TO TRACK AN
INDIVIDUAL. ON THE CONTRARY
THEY SIMPLY NEED TO HAVE
WIRELESS ACCESS TO DOWNLOAD
TRACKING SOFTWARE THAT WILL
PROVIDE INVESTIGATORS WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT THE SEEK.
SINCE CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
EXPLICITLY DEFINE THE TERM
DEVICE THERE IS AMBIGUITY
WHETHER THE DEVICE HAS TO BE A
MECHANICAL DEVICE OR NOT. SO
THIS BILL WOULD CLARIFY THAT A
TRACKING DEVICE INCLUDES ANY
SOFTWARE THAT PERMITS THE
TRACKING OF THE MOVEMENT OF A
PERSON OR OBJECT FOR PURPOSES
OF THE STATUE. OF SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS RAISED THE
CONCERN THAT THE BILL UNDER
THIS BILL WE ARE GRANTING NEW
POWERS SO TO GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES. ARE THAT IS NOT THE
CASE IN FACT THE AMENDMENT THAT
I REFERENCED EARLIER WILL
ADDRESS THAT PARTICULAR ISSUE.
ON EVER DOES NOT AND I'M
COMMITTED TO A CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TO- HAVE-
ALL REFINED THE LANGUAGE TO
MAKE IT BETTER SO WE GOT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. IN SUPPORT. WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. SO NOT NOT
EXACTLY OPPOSITION AT THIS
POINT- KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF
THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- WORK ON THIS AND THE
AMENDMENTS ARE WE'RE STILL IN
THE PROCESS OF REVIEWING TO SEE
IF THEY FULLY ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS BUT LOOK FORWARD TO.
WORKING WITH HIM TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE ARE ADDRESSED. THANK
YOU QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER. ALL
SECONDS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WE NEED A QUORUM TO US YET GOOD
POINT WE WILL HAVE TO WAIT ON
THE. MOTION AND SECOND BUT FOR
THE TIME BEING. MR CHAO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MUCH. ALL RIGHT
AND- WE WILL- GO AHEAD AND THAT
HAVE TO WAIT TO HAVE A QUORUM
TO VOTE ON THIS. THANK. YEAH
. I
SEE MR GRAYSON- IN THE ROOM SO-
MISTER GRAYSON IF YOU'RE READY
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL THE FLOOR
WILL BE YOURS AND WELCOME MR
GRAYSON HAS ITEM NUMBER TWO
EIGHTY SIX NINETY NINE. THAT'S
ON CREDIT SERVICES ORGANIZATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES THIS AFTERNOON I
BRING FORWARD AB SIX NINE NINE
RELATED TO CREDIT SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS BEFORE I START I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING CLOSELY
WITH MY OFFICE TO IMPROVE THE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S
BEEN A DELIGHT WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF CHAIR. AS YOU KNOW
CREDIT SERVICE ORGANIZATION
OFFER TO REPAIR A CONSUMER'S
CREDIT FILE EXCHANGE FOR
PAYMENT. TYPICAL SERVICES
INCLUDES SCORE ANALYSIS. ZERO
CHALLENGES AND CREDIT CREDITOR
INTERVENTIONS HOWEVER THERE ARE
A FEW INSTANCES WHERE THE
SERVICES LACK DISCLOSURES OF
WHAT SPECIFIC SERVICES A
CONSUMER IS PURCHASING AND
EQUALLY IMPORTANT DISCLOSURES
ON WHAT A SCARE SO HAS ACTUALLY
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE CLIENT.
CONSUMERS ARE LED TO BELIEVE
THAT BY SIMPLY HIRING THE SEA-
THE CS SO THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
CLEAN UP THEIR CREDIT FILE AND
IMPROVE THEIR FINANCIAL
STANDING HOWEVER. IS THE FACT
THAT NOBODY CAN ERASE THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF LEGITIMATE
UNPAID BILLS DEBTS OR
BANKRUPTCY SINCE THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL IN
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WE HAVE
SEEN NUMEROUS MEDIA STORIES
ABOUT THE COMMON PRACTICES OF
THIS INDUSTRY AND THE CONSUMER
PROTECTION FINANCE BUREAU HAS
FILED SUIT AGAINST TWO OF THE
LARGEST CREDIT. AND THE CFPB
HAS ALSO ISSUED A- IT'S THREE
ABOUT THE INDUSTRY TO BE CLEAR
THE AIM OF THIS BILL IS NOT TO
SHUT DOWN LEGITIMATE CREDIT
REPAIR AGAIN THIS BILL IS NOT
TO SHUT DOWN LEGITIMATE CREDIT
REPAIR CLEARLY INACCURATE
INFORMATION CAN GET INTO A OR
ONTO A CONSUMER'S CREDIT FILE
AND NAVIGATING THE PROCESS OF
REMOVING THAT INFORMATION CAN
BE VERY FRUSTRATING. AND TIME
CONSUMING WITH AB SIX NINETY
NINE WE ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT CONSUMERS HAVE THE
BEST POSSIBLE INFORMATION TO
KNOW WHAT SERVICES THEY ARE
PURCHASING AND WHAT ACTIONS A
REPAIR ORGANIZATION IS TAKING
ON THEIR BEHALF WHILE I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL DOES
HAVE SOME OPPOSITION FROM THE
CREDIT REPAIR INDUSTRY I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE HAD DOCTOR
THINGS AND I THINK WE'RE
HAPPENED DOWN THE- RIGHT TRACK.
WANT TO CONTINUE TO. THIS BILL
MOVES THROUGH THE PROCESS IF IT
WAS TO GET OUT OF THIS- COME
TODAY. WITH THAT IN MIND I
WOULD LIKE TO CLEARLY STATE
THAT I AM COMMITTED TO AMENDING
THE BILL AS NOTED ON PAGE TEN
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS FOR
THE MORE. I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE YOUR STAFF TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED IN
COMMENT FIVE OF THE ANALYSIS.
SPECIFICALLY THAT WE WILL WORK
TO ENSURE THAT THE FURNITURE OR
A FURNITURE- TREAT ANY
COMMUNICATION FORM OF THE C. S.
O. SENT ON BEHALF OF A CONSUMER
AS DIRECT COMMUNICATION FROM
THE CONSUMER THEMSELVES. I
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL WILL
LIKELY REQUEST NEW.
APPOINTMENTS TO PARAGRAPHS BOTH
IN V. IN SECTION THREE OF THE
BILL. AS AS REQUESTED BY OR AS
DISCUSSED WITH THE STAFF MISTER
CHAIR WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO-
REFER TO MY WITNESS MISTER
CLIFFORD THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
THE FULL WE GO TO A WITNESSES
LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. FOR
THE MEETING MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CHECK OUT
HERE CHAO HERE A KILEY.
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN COLOR ON
KALRA GALLAGHER IRWIN OBERNOLTE
SMITH. WICKS. ARE WE DO A
QUORUM OUT I'D LIKE ALSO TO
TAKE CARE OF THE CONSENT AGENDA
I LIKE TO HAVE A MOTION OUR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE CHAO. HI
OUT I KILEY. HI KILEY I'VE
BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN. BERMAN HI
CALDERON CALDERON AYE KALRA
GALLAGHER IRWIN. WHEN I
OBERNOLTE SMITH SMITH I WICKS
SEVEN THE CONSENT IS SO
APPROVED VOWED THAT HE IS AB
THREE TWENTY FIVE RAMOS AND
ALSO A. B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE
IN THAT SLOW SO LET'S A RESUME
OUR HEARING I LIKE TO GO TO
OFFERS WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU JOINING YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- CLIFF BURKE HERE IN
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX NINE NINE WE
BELIEVE AB SIX NINE NINE IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS COMMUNITY
BOTH FROM UNSCRUPULOUS
PRACTICES OF CREDIT REPAIR
ORGANIZATIONS. UNFORTUNATELY
CERTAIN PRACTICES OF THE REPAIR
INDUSTRY HAVE BEEN PROBLEMATIC
FOR A LONG TIME AND QUê NHà
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY
OR CALIFORNIA WILL PLACE YOUR
ACTED THE CREDIT SERVICES
ACTIVE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOUR
WHICH DECLARED THE LEGISLATURE
FARMS IN THE CLEAR HERE'S
CERTAIN ADVERTISING AND
BUSINESS PRACTICES THEMSELVES
CREDIT SERVICES ORGANIZATION. I
WORKED A FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
UPON THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
THE PURPOSE OF THIS TITLE ARE
TO PROVIDE PROSPECTIVE BUYERS
OF SERVICE CREDIT SERVICES.
NATION'S WITH PATIENT. INTEL
DECISIONS REGARDING PURCHASES
OF THESE SERVICES AND TO
PROTECT PUBLIC FROM UNFAIR OR
DECEPTIVE ADVERTISING AND
BUSINESS PRACTICES AND QUOTE
UNFORTUNATELY. PROBLEMS WITH
THE CREDIT REPAIR INDUSTRY
REMAIN TODAY FRONT PAGE NEWS.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINETEEN
THE CONSUMER FINANCIAL
PROTECTION BUREAU THE CUES
COMPANIES OF VIOLATING THE LAW
COLLECTING ILLEGAL FEES
DECEPTIVE PRACTICES IN CHARGING
CONSUMERS WITHOUT DELIVERING
RESULTS. AB SIX NINE NINE
PROVIDES THE FREE FIRST MAJOR
UPDATE AND EXPANSION OF
CALIFORNIA STATE PROTECTION
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AB
SIX NINE NINE REQUIRES CREDIT
REPAIR ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS WITH INFORMATION ON
SERVICES PERFORMED BEFORE
CHARGING CONSUMER REASONABLE
TIMELINES TO PREVENT ENDLESS
CHARGES FULLER DISCLOSURE OF
CONTRACT TERMS BEFORE A
CONTRACT IS EXECUTED. IN A
LISTING OF REGISTER CONSUMER
REPAIR ORGANIZATIONS ON THE
WEB. IMPORTANTLY FOR
CREDIBILITY OF THE PURPOSE
PROCESS AB SIX NINE NINE
REQUIRES DISCLOSURE OF THE REAL
SENDER OF THE COMMUNICATION.
THIS WILL PREVENT CIRCUMVENTION
OF THE ACT AND PROTECT CONSUMER
PRIVACY IN KNOWLEDGE OF WHAT IS
BEING DONE IN THEIR NAME.
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY OFTEN
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR
AUTHORIZATION. AT THE END OF
THE DAY AB SIX NINE NINE
PROTECTS CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
AND BUSINESSES FROM PRACTICES
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
RECOGNIZED AS TROUBLESOME FOR
MORE THAN FOUR DECADES. WELL IT
IS GOOD NEWS THAT THE C. F. P.
B. AND THE FTC ARE TAKING
ACTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
LEAVE PROTECTION OF CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
OF AB SIX NINE NINE. WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF OTHER
COMMITTEE STAFF AND OTHERS TO
AMEND THE BILL LAST WEEK TO
ENSURE THAT AB SIX NINE NINE IS
FAIR AND REASONABLE TALL
LEGITIMATE CREDIT REPAIR
ORGANIZATIONS. AND NOT UNDULY
BURDENSOME AND SOME THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY AND THE
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE ISSUES
THAT REMAIN- REMAINS IN THE
PART OF OUR INDUSTRY I AS A
SPONSORS OF THE BILL. NO ONE
HERE IS INTERESTED IN ANYBODY
OUT OF BUSINESS OR MAKING THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL ON WORKABLE IT'S
ABOUT PROTECTING CONSUMERS AND
LEGITIMATE BUSINESSES AND
INDUSTRIES IN CALIFORNIA FROM
UNSCRUPULOUS PRACTICES AND WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE I HAVE HERE
WITH ME- CINDY AKLAN WHO IS THE
LEAD SHARE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COLLECTORS. TALK
A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE OF THE RUBBLE
LETTERS. THANK YOU WELCOME AND
MR CHAIRING FELLOW COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU- AS CLIFFORD
MENTION I'M CURRENTLY MY NAME
IS CINDY OFTEN I'M CURRENTLY
SERVING AS LEGISLATIVE CHAIR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COLLECTORS AND I AM ALSO A
SECOND GENERATION COLLECTION
AGENCY OWNER WITH AN OFFICE
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I'M AB
SIXTY NINE IS SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLECTORS AS A DIRECT RESULT
OF CONSUMER PROTECTION ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY
OUR MEMBERS IN ON BEHALF OF
COLLECTION AGENCIES NATIONWIDE.
EACH DAY. COLLECTION AGENCIES
RECEIVE BASS GENERATED LETTERS
FROM ZEROS ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMERS DISPUTING THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO THE
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES FOR
SIGNED ACCOUNTS. HUNDREDS AND
IN SOME INSTANCES THOUSANDS
MAYBE RECEIVED BY OUR MEMBERS.
EACH LETTER APPEARS IN THE SAME
FORMAT TYPESET AND REQUEST
VALIDATION AND DOCUMENTATION
FOR THE REPORTED ACCOUNT AND OR
A DELETION FROM THE CONSUMER'S
CREDIT FILE. THE LETTERS ALL
CONTAIN A WET OR ORIGINAL
SIGNATURE OF THE CONSUMERS NAME
THE DISPUTES ARE PROCESSED BY
OUR MEMBERS AND VALIDATION IS
MAILED AT THE CONSUMER REQUEST.
CONSISTENTLY OUR MEMBERS HAVE
REPORTED THAT CONSUMERS DID NOT
ACTUALLY DISPUTE THE AMOUNT
ASSIGNED. THEY HAVE INDICATED
THAT THE SIGNATURE IN THE
LETTER IS NOT THEIR SIGNATURE.
THEY'VE EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION
AND ANGER AS THEIR CREDIT SCORE
DID NOT INCREASE AT THIS THIS
ZERO HAD REPRESENTED. THEY HAVE
PAID FOR SERVICES TO A C. R. O.
WITH NO RESULTS. THEY'RE
UNAWARE THAT THE LETTERS ARE
BEING SENT ON PAID ACCOUNTS.
AND MULTIPLE LETTERS ARE MAILED
AT THEIR COST FOR ACCOUNTS
PREVIOUSLY VALIDATED. ON BEHALF
OF CONSUMERS EIGHTY SIX NINE
NINE IS INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMAN TIM GRAYSON AND
SPONSORED BY SEE AC TO REVISE
THE EXISTING NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR ACT INCREASED TRANSPARENCY
AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
DISCLOSURES TO CONSUMERS FOR
THE SERVICES PROVIDED BY THIS
YEAR AS- WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND YOUR AYE
THAT TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ARE ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS SO PLEASE
COME UP AND IDENTIFY YOURSELF.
TIM LYNCH ON BEHALF OF THE
RECEIVABLES MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION INTERNATIONAL AND
APOLOGIES FOR THE LATE NOTICE
BUT AS OF THIS MORNING WE ARE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU MUCH ANNEX PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
MELANIE CUEVAS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION
ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON VANESSA
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF ENCORE
CAPITAL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MUCH. OPPOSITION PLACE COME ON
UP. IF I COULD ASK YOU TO MAKE
WAY FOR OPPOSITION AB ONE OF
YOU. WELCOME HERE I GET
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WONDERFUL TO SEE YOU ALL AGAIN
HI MY NAME IS RUNOFF DAYLAMI
WITH NELSON MARKS MURDER HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT
LEXINGTON LAW WITH ME TODAY AS
LEXINGTON'S COUNCIL ERIC CAMERA
AT WHO IS HERE TO SPEAK BRIEFLY
REGARDING HOW LEXINGTON
OPERATES- AND TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IF YOU. THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. FUNDAMENTALLY AS A DSL OR
CREDIT SERVICE ORGANIZATION WE
ARE THE SUBJECT OF THIS
LEGISLATION EIGHTY SIX NINE
NINE. TRUTHFULLY AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF CONSUMERS
AND DISPUTES AGAINST DEBT
COLLECTORS IT'S A LITTLE ODD
DEFINE OURSELVES AS THE TARGET
A CONSUMER PROTECTION
LEGISLATION WERE OP THAT
SPONSOR STAND TO BENEFIT IF WE
ARE UNSUCCESSFUL AND HELPING
THE CONSUMER IN THE PROCESS OF
DISPUTING AND REMOVING ARONIE
US ARE OBSOLETE DEBT. FROM
THEIR RECORDS BUT HERE WE ARE-
WE KNOW THE AUTHOR'S INTENT TO
BE ONE OF CONSUMER PROTECTION-
SO WE WANT TO FOCUS ON THE FACT
THAT CONSUMERS DO BENEFIT FROM
CREDIT REPAIR SERVICES. AND WE
AGREE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT AND A
LEGITIMATE GOAL OF SUCH
LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE CLARITY
TO THE CONSUMER ABOUT WHAT
SERVICES THEY'RE GETTING HOW
THEY'RE GETTING THEM WHEN
THEY'RE GETTING THEM- AS WELL
AS GETTING UPDATES ON THOSE
SERVICES JUST AS IT JUST AS IT
IS AN IMPORTANT AND LEGITIMATE
GOAL TO PROVIDE APOTEX THEIR
PRIVACY. BY REDACTING THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION- OF COURSE
AS LONG AS YOU DON'T ADD PUT
THIS YES SO IN A BIND BY
REQUIRING THEM TO REDACT
INFORMATION AT THE SAME TIME
THAT THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE THE
FULL INFORMATION- SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE PLEASED TO SEE THAT
THE- PALACES AND- DROP. WHAT WE
DON'T BELIEVE WOULD BE APPROACH
IT- ARE PROVISIONS CLEAR. MIND
TO ROAD ABILITY OF CSOS TO DO
THEIR JOBS- THAT SAID WHERE WE
ARE TODAY IS IN A MUCH BETTER
POSITION THAN WHERE WE WERE.
EVEN YESTERDAY SO BEFORE I GO
ANY FURTHER. I JUST WANT TO
STOP AND SAY WE REALLY THANK
MISTER GRAYSON THE AUTHOR
OFFERS HARD WORK AND WE THINK
THE COMMITTEE. I'M HERE TO
STAFF SPEND A- LONG AMOUNT OF
TIME MORE THAN AN HOUR LAST
WEEK SITTING DOWN WITH US GOING
THROUGH THE BILL IN DETAIL.
THROUGH ALL OF OUR CONCERNS
EACH OF THE PROVISIONS THAT WE
FELT THAT WERE INTENDED TO
PERHAPS HELP THE CONSUMER BUT
POTENTIALLY HAD UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SO WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT- WE ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT. FOR AN EXCELLENT
JOB AN ANALYSIS. FOR
HIGHLIGHTING MANY OF THE SAME
ISSUES THAT CLEARLY AND
CONCISELY- WE THINK THE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
AMENDMENTS- THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
ACCEPTED HERE TODAY- WE BELIEVE
THAT THOSE AMENDMENTS HAVE.
REALLY TAKEN OUT MANY OF THE
PROVISIONS THAT WE FELT WERE
DESIGNED TO HELP THE DEBT
COLLECTORS AND NOT TO PROTECT
THE- CONSUMER AND HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY MOVE THE BILL IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. SELL
BECAUSE OF THAT I THINK THIS IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS TO
STAY HERE TODAY WE WERE AND
THEN OPPOSE POSITION WE ARE
MOVING TEN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. SO THAT WE
THINK THE AUTHOR AGAIN- THE
REASON WE REMAIN AND OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED A POSITION
VERSUS OUR FAVORITE TWEEN OR
POSITION OF. CONCERNS IS
BECAUSE WE ARE PLEASED WITH THE
DIRECTION IT HAS TAKEN BUT
THERE IS A THE BIGGEST ISSUE IN
THIS LEGISLATION STILL REMAINS
AND WE FEEL IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE- FIND RESOLUTION ON
THIS AND- THIS IS THE ONE THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS MADE A
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT ON IT
WE'RE THANKFUL BUT- IS WHAT I
WILL CALL THAT DO NOT
IMPERSONATE POTS AND THE- FIRE.
ITSELF AS SUBDIVISIONS AND ENVY
OF SECTION THREE. I'M I WANT TO
BE CLEAR AGAIN THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY TAKE AUTHORED A
BIRD. THAT IT IS NOT HIS SCHOOL
TO SHUT DOWN CREDIT REPAIR
ORGANIZATIONS WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S AS INTENSE. BUT WE
DO BELIEVE THAT'S THAT FACT OF
THOSE TWO SUBDIVISIONS RIGHT
NOW- SO WERE EXTREMELY HARD BY
ITS COMMITMENT- BACK AND WE
ARE. APPRECIATE THAT THE
ANALYSIS- INCORPORATE THAT
CONCEPT. OF A REQUIREMENT OF
THE DATA FURNITURE- AS TREE ANY
COMMUNICATION FROM A CSS SENT
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER AS A
DIRECT COMMUNICATION FROM THE
CONSUMER THEMSELVES. WE THINK
IT'S CRUCIAL AND NOT COMING TO
A RESOLUTION ON THIS ISSUE IS
FOR LACK OF A BETTER PHRASE
IT'S THE WHOLE BALL GAME- STE.
THE FACT THAT CREDIT REPAIR
ORGANIZATIONS ARE FACED WITH
THIS CHOICE. IT'S NOT IDEAL
IT'S NOT ANYONE'S IEA ALL IT'S
A CREATURE FEDERAL LAW. BY ANY
REPRESENTATION THAT THEY DO
THIS WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE AND
AUTHORIZATION OR CONSENT TO THE
CONSUMER. IT IGNORES THE FACT
THAT CSOS HAVE CONTRACTS WITH
THEIR CLIENTS IT'S JUST NOT
TRUE THEY'RE NOT OUT THERE
ACTING ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CLIENTS WITHOUT ANY AGENCY OR
BECAUSE OF ANY- ANTI CONSUMER
INTENT. I IT'S NOT NECESSARY
YES THEY DO THIS BECAUSE IF
THEY DIDN'T THE DEBT COLLECTOR
FURNITURE AS THEY'RE CALLED
UNDER FEDERAL LAW AND
REGULATIONS. THEY COULD TAKE
THEIR LETTERS AND PUT IT TO THE
SIDE THERE WOULD BE RENDERED
INEFFECTIVE IN REPRESENTING THE
CONSUMER WHO HIRED THEM. IT'S
HIGHLIGHTED THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS UNDER FEDERAL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THE FURNITURE'S
ONLY OBLIGATION TO INVESTIGATE
A DISPUTE IS WHEN THEY GET A
DISPUTE FROM THE CONSUMER
THEMSELF THERE'S AN EXPRESS
EXEMPTION. FOR AT THE
FURNITURE'S OBLIGATION TO
INVESTIGATE IF THERE'S A
REASONABLE BELIEF THAT THE
DISPUTE WAS REPAIRED ON BEHALF
OF THE CONSUMER BY OR-
SUBMITTED BY A CREDIT REPAIR
ORGANIZATION THAT IS. AND BLACK
OR WHITE LETTERS SO WHAT THIS
DOES IT GIVES SOME CERTAINTY
THEY NO LONGER HAVE TO HAVE A
REASONABLE BELIEF AND IN VEGAS
UNCERTAINTY. SO THAT SAID WE
KNOW THE AUTHOR IS MADE THE
COMMITMENT WE ABSOLUTELY KNOW
THAT HE WANTS TO GET THE
LANGUAGE RIGHT. WE WANT HIM TO
GET IT RIGHT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HIM TO
HELP YOU GET THERE. WE SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WERE ACTUALLY PART OF THE
SOLUTION- AND WITH THAT MR
TERABITS OKAY WITH YOU- I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MY
CLIENT JUST FOR A COUPLE
MINUTES- I THINK. IF YOU'D
RATHER HAVE AN JUST ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS OF NOTHING ELSE- I
THINK MY CLIENT DISAGREES WITH
THE CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
LAWSUIT AND IF HE COULD JUST
SAY A WORD ABOUT THAT THAT
WOULD BE MUCH APPRECIATED I
KNOW IT TOOK A LOT OF. TIME
PLEASE DO. WELCOME THANK YOU-
YES WHAT I'D LIKE TO MENTION A
FEW POINTS ON THE LAWSUIT- THAT
WE'VE HEARD NOW TWICE- THERE IS
NO ALLEGATION IN THE LAWSUIT
THAT PEOPLE DID NOT RECEIVE THE
SERVICES THAT THEY CONTRACTED
FOR- THAT IS NOT A PART OF THE
LAWSUIT- THERE IS A BILLING
QUESTION THE CFPB HAS AN
INTERPRETATION OF LAW THE
DELAYS BILLING FOR SIX MONTHS
AND THE ALLEGATION IS THE
BILLING OCCURRED PRIOR TO SIX
MONTHS AFTER THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES- SOMETIMES THAT GETS
CONFLATED WITH AN- UP FRONT FEE
THAT SUGGEST PRIOR TO THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES. EXISTING
FEDERAL LAW AND CALIFORNIA LAW
REQUIRES THAT SERVICES BE
DELIVERED FIRST AND BILLING
OCCUR LATER- SO IT NEITHER OF
THOSE CHARACTERIZATIONS AS
ACCURATE. YEAH IF I MAY LIKE TO
PRIDE JUST A LITTLE BACKGROUND
ON. WHAT THE SERVICES ARE THAT
WOULD BE TO HELP MAKE IT. YES
JUST BRIEFLY. THIS COMMITTEE IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IS.
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE FOR THIS
MATTER- NOT BECAUSE OF THE
LANGUAGE IN THE AMENDMENT BUT
BECAUSE CREDIT. REPORTING IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A PRIVACY ISSUE.
IT'S ABOUT OUR DATA IT'S ABOUT
THE WAY OUR DATA FLOWS BETWEEN
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES AND IT'S
ABOUT HOW THOSE BUSINESSES USE
THAT DATA. FUNDAMENTALLY OUR
WORK IS TO INSERT CONSUMERS
INTO THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
THEM THAT OCCURS RELATIVE TO
THEIR DATA. AND SO AT ITS CORE
THE WORK THAT WE DO IS ABOUT
PRIVACY WHAT PEOPLE CAN SAY
ABOUT US AND HOW WE CAN
INTERVENE IN THAT MATTER WE
SPECIFICALLY FOCUS OUR
ATTENTION ON THE THREE CONSUMER
REPORTING AGENCIES THE
INFORMATION THAT APPEARS ON
THOSE CREDIT REPORTS. AND
PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH TOOLS SO
THAT THEY CAN MAKE SURE THAT
INFORMATION IS NOT ONLY
ACCURATE BUT THAT IT IS FAIR
AND THAT CAN BE SUBSTANTIATED
BECAUSE IF PEOPLE ARE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT US AND
ABOUT OUR DATA. THEY BETTER
HAVE THE DOCUMENTATION TO
DEMONSTRATE WHY SOMETHING%
APPEARS ON A CREDIT REPORT AND
WHAT THE JUSTIFICATION IS
THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE DO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION TO
BILL PLEASE COME ON UP AND
IDENTIFY YOURSELF. SEEING NONE
NOT SLL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I KNOW
GO AHEAD MISGUIDED GOT THAT
EMOTION. YES BILLS BEEN MOVED.
GO AHEAD MISS KILEY SO THE KEYS
FOR THE OPPOSITION IS THIS DO
NOT IMPERSONATE PROVISION AND
SO- YOUR ARGUMENT IS THAT IN
LAST THE C. R. O. USES THE NAME
OF THE CONSUMER AND
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CONSUMER THERE'S NO OBLIGATION
UNDER FEDERAL LAW- FOR THE
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES
RESPOND IS THAT RIGHT. OKAY SO.
IF IT WAS A LOT OF THE SAID THE
YOU KNOW- THE NAME OF THE
ORGANIZATION AND SAID ACTING AS
AN AGENT OF ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER WHY WOULD THAT NOT
WORK. BECAUSE THEN THEY HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT HEY ARE NOT THE
CONSUMER AND SO UNDER THE
EXEMPTION UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
THEY DON'T THE- FURNITURE
DOESN'T HAVE A DUTY TO
INVESTIGATE THERE'S AN
EXEMPTION. IS THE EXEMPTION
DEFINITIVELY DOESN'T APPLY TO
THE AGENT OF THE- OF THE
CONSUMER IT LITERALLY SAYS IF
THERE IS A REASONABLE BELIEF
THAT SOMEONE IS ACTING ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER. OR THAT
THEY ARE THAT IT IS BEING FOR
FAST SUBMITTED BY A CREDIT
REPAIR ORGANIZATION. THEY DON'T
HAVE TO. FIVE RESPOND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO DO THE
INVESTIGATIONTHE SAME MANNER
THEY WOULD WITH A CONSUMER
DISPUTE. I SEE IS THAT THE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE AUTHOR OR
SUPPORTERS. SO WE'RE WORKING
ON- TRYING TO TIGHTEN UP
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE AND OF
COURSE- CLIFFORD CAN GIVE
ANSWERS WELL BUT WE THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ADDRESSING. IN THOSE TWO
SECTIONS THAT I MADE A
COMMITMENT ON TRYING TO FIND
LANGUAGE. THAT WOULD TIGHTEN
THAT UP TO MAKE SURE BECAUSE
OUR INTENT IS NOT. TO AN ABLE-
THERE TO BE NO RESPONSE. GOOD
ARMED I MEAN IF I WOULD AGREE
WITH THEM IN THE I THINK THE
AUTHOR HAS WILL SET IT. I WOULD
JUST ADD THAT YOU KNOW IS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THAT WAS
NOT OUR INTENT. YEAH WE'RE NOT
SURE THE LAW REALLY WORKS THE
WAY IT'S BEEN TO DESCRIBE
CLEARLY FEDERAL LAW. REQUIRES
US TO RESPOND TO A CONSUMER
WHEN THEY MAKE. IT WHEN THEY
CHALLENGE THE VALIDITY OF IT
YET BUT IT THAT REQUIRES A
RESPONSE AND THAT THE WHOLE.
YOU VALIDATING THE DEATH SO
WHEN YOU GET THOUSANDS OF
WROBEL LETTERS THAT WERE NOT
ACTUALLY SIGNED BY THE
CONSUMER. AND YOU'RE PUTTING IN
PLAY THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION
THROUGH THE MAIL AS WELL AS
CREATING WORK WE'RE TRYING
WE'RE TRYING TO. DO NARROW DOWN
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE. ARM. TO
SEND A LETTER. TO DISCLOSE WHO
THE ACTUAL CENTER IS SPEAKS TO
ENFORCE THE LAW AGAINST WHAT'S
ACTUALLY PROVE IT IN THE LAW HE
SERVE ACTUALLY NEED TO KNOW WHO
SENT IT. BUT BUT- IT'S NOT OUR
INTENT NOT TO RESPOND SO THE IT
YOU KNOW. THE ASSERTION THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO RESPOND IS
OF COURSE BOTH IS A MATTER OF
OUR A CHANCE. WHICH THERE'S
NOTHING A LIMITS ARE. THERE'S
NOTHING THAT WOULD LIMIT. US
RESPONDING THEY'RE THEY'RE JUST
WILL SAY WE'RE NOT REQUIRED TO
YOU WHAT WE HAVE SUGGESTED IT
IN THE RECEIVED IN HIS EARLY.
IS A- DUPLICATIVE OR STATE
VERSION OF THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS JUSTIN BUT THEIR
CONCERNS AT REST. BECAUSE IT IS
NOT OUR INTENT TO USE THIS. TO
AVOID RESPONDING. I'M JUST.
THAT'S NOT A REASON FLYER
SAYING YOU HAVE A STATE VERSION
OF THAT REQUIREMENT THAT
EXTENDS TO SOMEONE ACTING AS AN
AGENT OF THE CONSUMER RIGHT. IN
WHICH THIS YEAR BECAUSE AGAIN
WE'RE- MISTER GREAT IN AS THE
AUTHOR CLEARLY. IS HAS
COMMITTED TO WORK WITH THIS
WITH THE VERY BEST PARTY TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN SO THAT. YOU
KNOW THIS AREA THEY DESCRIBE
DOESN'T HAPPEN I SAY IT IS NOT
OUR. GOAL TO MAKE TO HAVE.
HAPPENED SO. THIS OUT IN FOR
THE OPPOSITION OF ROBO LETTERS
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY DO IS THERE A
LEGITIMATE PURPOSE OF THIS HOW
DO YOU RESPOND TO THAT. I THINK
I GOT A LITTLE BIT CONFUSED
THERE I THINK THE SUBJECT OF
THIS WAS TO HELP THE CONSUMER
AND NOT TO. REDUCE THE WORKLOAD
AT THE DEBT COLLECTOR SO THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON. I
THINK THE NUMBER OF LETTERS IS
BASED ON THE NUMBER OF THINGS
TO DISPUTE. SO BUT IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THAT YOU'RE DISPUTING
WITHOUT THERE BEING A
REASONABLE BASIS TO BELIEVE
THAT IT MIGHT BE DISPUTABLE AS
THAT THE ALLEGATION FROM. JACK
LET ME CALIFORNIA ON THE
CLEARED FACT THE OLD THE
EXISTING LAW THAT YOU CAN
ADVISE YOUR CHARACTERIZATION.
YOU CAN ADVISE SUMER TO
DISPUTES. THOUGHT SOMETHING
THAT YOU OTHERWISE NO IS NO IS
VALID. ARMS SIMILARLY THERE IS
IT THERE ARE DEBTS OR CREDIT.
THAT GETS PAID PAID OFF THAT
IT'S ALREADY BEEN RESOLVED IN
WHICH WE STILL GETTING LETTERS
CHALLENGING SO I MEAN THERE'S A
WHOLE HOST. AND I CAN BRING
SEND TO THE COLLECTION AGENCY
PERSON BACK UP HERE LET ME JUST
SAY THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF
REASONS WHY A LOT OF THE
LETTERS THAT ARE SAD. ARE
INACCURATE. ARE NOT CARAFES-
THERE TEND TO BE A TEMPLATE SO
THESE ARE NOT INDIVIDUALIZE
LETTERS. WHEN WE HAVE A OF THE
LETTERS THAT WE THEY'RE ALL THE
SAME LETTER THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS FOR CONSUMER. TO
CONSUMER. NAME IS JUST STAFF
WIDER IF THAT. AND OUT ALLERGY
THANK MMHM SO OKAY I DO YOU
GUYS WATER RESPONSE ARE ADDED
ME TO INVITE BACK AND FORTH. NO
WHERE IN MY COMP PRESENTATION
OF ANY PARTICULAR COMPANY YEAH
I'M JUST TELLING YOU WHAT THE
INDUSTRY PRACTICE ARM WALL.
TROUBLING AND I THINK I MADE IT
CLEAR IN MY PRESENTATION OF
THIS BILL IS INTENDED TO HELP
CONSUMERS AND THE LEGITIMATE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY WHICH IS WHY
YOU SEE SUCH BROAD BUSINESS
SUPPORT FOR THANK YOU LET'S
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION AGAIN
ONE. EIGHT SO I THINK THERE ARE
TWO POINTS TWO QUESTIONS. ONE
QUESTION THAT YOU MADE IS- IS
THERE A BASIS FOR SENDING
LETTERS AND I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
THAT QUESTION AND THEN THE IDEA
OF USING TEMPLATES REFORMS. SO
WITH RESPECT TO A BASIS FOR US.
AN APPROPRIATE BASIS UNDER THE
LAW IS SUBSTANTIATION. AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
CONSUMERS OFTEN HAVE NO SENSE
OF WHO A DEBT COLLECTOR IS WHAT
THEIR BUSINESS NAME IS THEY
SIMPLY SEE AN ITEM ON THEIR
CREDIT REPORT. AND SO OFTEN THE
QUESTION THAT WE POPE WAS IS
WHO ARE YOU WHERE THIS COME
FROM LISA THE NTA CREDIT REPORT.
NO ASSERTION IT'S NOT TERRACE
IT'S BEST TO GET. THE SECOND
POINT THIS NOTION OF THERE'S
SOMETHING INHERENTLY WRONG WITH
USE THAT TEMPLATE THE DEBT
COLLECTORS AS A MATTER OF
PRACTICE SEND EVERYTHING AS A
TEMPLATE THE ONLY THING THAT
CHANGES IS THE INFORMATION FROM
THE CONSUMER. AND SO THE IDEA
THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
INHERENTLY WRONG WITH US USING
APPROVED TEMPLATES FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE- I THINK IS A SPECIOUS
ARGUMENT IT IT MAKES NO SENSE
ATTORNEYS USE TEMPLATE ALL OF
THE TIME THERE'S NO REASON TO
REINVENT THE WHEEL THERE'S NO-
THERE'S NOTHING NEFARIOUS ABOUT
USING A TEMPLATE AND USING THE
SAME LETTER FOR THE SAME
PURPOSE. AGAIN IT'S THEY DO
TIME AND TIME AGAIN. NUMBER
THAT I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE YOU
THAT FEDERAL LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AFTER THE FACT AND
IT'S TOO LATE FOR THIS
COMMITTEE OBVIOUSLY BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF THE FLOOR- WILL
ALSO SEE THAT THERE IS. A
PROVISION TALK ABOUT FRIVOLOUS
OR OR RELEVANT DISPUTES THERE
ARE WAYS OF HANDLING THINGS IF
YOU THINK THERE'S NO BASIS FOR
SOMETHING WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS GETTING IN THE FRONT
DOOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
BELIEVE OUT OF THE RUBBLE
LETTER SITUATION HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED BY ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS- TAKEN. AND THAT
PLACES THE BUT ESSENTIAL PLACE
THE BURDEN ON THE- SEE A SOUL
TO VERIFY THE INFORMATION IS
NOT OBSOLETE IN. AN ACCURATE I
THINK THAT'S THE OF AMENDMENT
NUMBER THREE ITEM THE MICHIGAN
BUT I ALSO AGREE THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S PROBLEMATIC TO PROVIDE A
FRESH. NEW WHERE THE
INFORMATION IS COME QUICKLY
FROM THE FROM THE CONSUMER
VERSUS YOU KNOW ON BEHALF OF
THE INSTRUMENTS SO I THINK THAT
HAS TO BE FIXED. SO I'M GLAD
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS AGREED TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT- AND-
YOU KNOW SO LONG AS- I HAVE
YOUR COMMITMENT AND I'M I'M I'M
OKAY WITH. THE WITH THE BILL
GOING FOR A MISS SMITH GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THE
CONCERN THAT I HAVE AS WELL
INTENTIONED AS THIS BILL IS IN
AROUND CONSUMER PROTECTION IS
THAT IS. IN THIS ETIRE SPACE
OF CREDIT AND CREDIT REPORTING.
THE CONSUMER. A SENSIBLY HAS
NUMEROUS PROTECTIONS OF BOTH
THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE LEVEL
ALL OF THOSE PROTECTIONS
HOWEVER ARE ONLY AS GOOD AS
THEIR ABILITY TO BE ENFORCED ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER. AS
CONSUMERS WHO FIND THEMSELVES
IN THE SITUATION NEED OF THESE
SERVICES. ARE PRBABLY THE
LEAST LIKELY AMONG ALL
CONSUMERS TO HAVE THE BAND
WITH. TO THEN PURSUE ADDITIONAL
LEGAL HELP AND SUPPORT AS
NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR%
RIGHTS ARE BEING PROTECTED. SO
I WOULD SAY THAT RELUCTANTLY I
WILL SUPPORT TODAY BUT WHAT I
WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE ADDED
AS THE FINAL PIECE BEFORE IT
COMES BACK TO US FOR A FINAL
VOTE WOULD BE. THAT ENFORCEMENT
COMPONENT AND IS IT MEANINGFUL
AND IS IT EASILY ACCESSIBLE BY
CONSUMERS IN THE INTENT- YOU
KNOW WITH WHICH YOU AUTHORED
THE BILL. SO. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. I DO
WANT TO ADD THAT THE I DO
RESERVE MY RIGHT TO CALL THE
BILL BACK IN THE EVENT THAT IT
DOES NOT GET ADDRESS A- OR ANY
OTHER ISSUES THAT MAY COME UP
BETWEEN NOW AND- WHENEVER. SAID
I APPRECIATE THAT. IF THERE ARE
NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST SIMPLY- MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR GIVING US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD AND
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
FOR HEARING IT FOR THE GOOD
QUESTIONS. IWANT TO THINK
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE HAVE
HAD- SO- SUBSTANTIAL
DISCUSSIONS WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY SOME OF THE THINGS WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY WE'RE JUST
RECENTLY BROUGHT UP TO THE
POINT THAT WE REALLY DIDN'T
HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO DO SOME
DUE DILIGENCE- HOWEVER THROUGH
COMMITMENTS AND WILLINGNESS TO
BE ABLE TO BRING IT BACK- IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE COMMITTED
TO. A SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT AND ADDRESS ISSUES
ESPECIALLY ENFORCEMENT WHICH WE
HAVE STARTED TO DO AND
PENALTIES AS WELL AS WORKING
WITH THE AG'S SELL WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED UP AND
YOU TO IN. A BILLS OUT THE
MOTION. TO APPROVE CAN A MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CHAU HI I KILEY BY KILEY AYE
POWER A HAND. FOR ME. BERMAN I
CALL THE OTHER ON HI KALRA.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING ARE WHEN.
WHEN I OBERNOLTE SMITH SMITH I
WEEKS. THE BILL IS OUT SIX TWO
ZERO SO FAR WILL HOLD IT OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL THAT
BRINGS US TO THE MISTER CHAD.
AND HE HAD US- ITEM NUMBER ONE
A. B. FOR NINETY NINE WELCOME A
MISTER MAYES. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. I THINK IT'S CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE I THINK
YOU THE CHANCE TO PRESENT AB
FOUR NINE NINE. THE COURT OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
SINCE THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOP APARTMENT ET
DE HAS SENT MORE THAN SEVENTEEN
MILLION PIECES OF MAIL
CONTAINING FORCES SO SECURITY
NUMBERS UNNECESSARILY EXPOSING
CALIFORNIA'S IDENTITY. IDENTITY
THEFT. MR JOBS LIKE ME TO
CONTINUE ON ON. THIS QUESTION.
OKAY THE OKAY- LET'S JUST CELL
LET ME SKIP A COUPLE OF LINES
HERE'S A THIS BODY IS CONTINUE
TAKEN STEPS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM IDENTITY
THEFT IN A BEFORE NINE IS IT'S
NEXT THAT MIGHT THIS
LEGISLATION INCORPORATE STATE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS BY
PROHIBITING THE MAILING OF THE
SO SECURITY NUMBERS UNLESS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRING AGENCIES REPORT BACK
ON THE USE OF SO SECURING
NUMBERS AND PROVIDE A PROPER
IDENTITY DANTE SEPARATE PROTECT
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION TO
AFFECTED INDIVIDUALS SO
RESPECTED REQUEST AND I FELT
VERY GOOD THE AYE YOU ACCEPT.
AMENDMENTS YES YEAH THERE'S A
YES BIGGEST. SUPPORT THE SECOND
FORT. SEE NINE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NINE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS I MISSED
KILEY AND FOLLOW THE SIZE THIS
IS GOING TO REQUIRE EVERY
AGENCY TO SUBMIT A REPORT IT
KIND OF SEEMS LIKE THAT'S GOING
TO BE A LOT OF. REPORTING HIS
MUSIC HAVE A PROHIBITION ON
pTHAT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
DEAL WITH THE PROHIBITION IS A
FIFTY FEDERAL AUSTIN OUT AND
FLEX YET THINK WE TOOK
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE- BUT YEAH I
AGREE I MEAN EVEN LOOK AT THE
RIGHT THE RECOMMENDATION IT WAS
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY TWO IT
WAS UP TO ME IF WE CAN MAKE IT
HAPPEN RIGHT NOW I MEAN I DON'T
KNOW WHY STATE AGENCIES- CAN'T
JUST STOP DOING IT- BUT OF
COURSE THERE'S THE BUREAUCRACY
AND THERE'S- THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN PROGRAMS AND STATES THAT I.
MAKE IT MAKE IT CHALLENGING SO
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH
APPROPRIATIONS THE TO DO SOME
TECHNICAL BUT CLEAN UPS AS WELL
BUT I WOULD PREFER THAT- BUT
YOU KNOW WILL WORK IN. RETURN
TO WORK. FOR THE TEAM MISSED
AND THANK YOU AND YEAH THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY REALLY IMPORTANT OF.
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT I DIDN'T
SEE ADDRESS WAS THE
CONFIDENTIALITY OF WHAT'S-
AGENCY USES THOSE- SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS BECAUSE OF
COURSE AT THAT LIST WOULD BE A
GREAT LIST FOR- HACKERS TO HAVE
FOR A HE USED TO HAVE SO IT IS
YOUR INTENTION TO MAKE THE
LIST. CONFIDENCE WE HAVEN'T-
BUT- IF YOU'VE GOT ANY IDEAS
AND- MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF IF YOU'VE GOT ANY IDEAS
ON ON SOME LANGUAGES INTO THE
BILL FORD BE HAPPY TO DO THAT
AT ITS IT WOULD BE AT NOT GREAT
IF THE- PRESS. PUTS OUT THERE
THAT THE- BUT WE ALREADY KNOW
EDT IS THE AGENCY THAT HAS SOME
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES. AND IT
WOULD BE I THINK NOT
NECESSARILY BENEFICIAL TO HAVE
ALL THAT INFORMATION OUT OF THE
PUBLIC BUT I THINK THAT'S KNOWN
PHENOMENA AUDITOR ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED ITS PUBLIC- BUT
PROBABLY NO HE WE ALL YES THAT
THERE'S THERE HAVE BEEN. MANY
STORIES SO IN AN EASY TO USE
EXCUSE IS ALWAYS. YOU KNOW THEY
THEY NEED TO DEVELOP THE
SOFTWARE AND THAT'S GONNA TAKE.
ANOTHER TEN YEAR SO- I THINK
IT'S GOOD TO PRESS ON THIS
ISSUE. I DO THINK THAT
COMPLIANCE FOR THIS IS GOING TO
BE. REALLY REALLY EXPENSIVE NOT
TO SAY THAT WE SHOULDN'T DO IT-
BUT- I MEAN I THINK WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT PEOPLE UNDERSTAND YOU
SHOULDN'T BE USING SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBERS AS OFTEN AS
YOU DO I DIED. AND SCHOOLS ARE
STILL COLLECTING ON THE DOCTORS
ARE STILL COLLECTING ON THE WE
REALLY NEED TO CHANGE. THAT
HABIT BUT I THINK THOSE ARE
KIND OF THAT THE- POTENTIALITY
THING I REALLY HOPE THAT YOU.
GET GOING FORWARD. AND COST. IS
THE COST. YEP. MUCH ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. IN THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED TO OUR IT
WILL GOAL TO APPROPRIATIONS
WORD THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN UP ALSO WITH THAT- WHICH
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECT THE
REQUEST I WROTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TELL HI SO I KILEY KILEY AYE
BAUER CAN BERMAN. BERMAN I
CALDERON CALDERON HI KALRA
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I OR ONE-
WHEN I OBERNOLTE SMITH SMITH I
WEEKS THE BILL WITHOUT SEVEN
ZERO SO FAR THE WAS CHECK YOU
VERY MUCH OUT WE NEED A MOTION
ON THE CHILD BILL WHICH WAS
PRESENTED TO. I DO I HAVE A
SECOND. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON AB NINE OH FOR
ITEM NUMBER THREE AND THAT WAS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR
YES CHAO HI SO I KILEY. KILEY
AYE BAUER QUE HAN BERMAN.
BERMAN I CALDERON CALDERON AYE
KALRA. GALLAGHER GALLAGHER I OR
ONE. OBERNOLTE IRWIN. WHEN I
OBERNOLTE SMITH SMITH I WEEKS
WEEKS HI THE BILL ITSELF DOWN A
TWO ZERO. ARMS AND THE CAN CAN
WE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON
ON LET'S START AT THE TOP RIGHT
NOW SO- ITEM NUMBER ONE AB FOR
NINETY NINE MAYES PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BUT OUR QUE
HAN KALRA. OBERNOLTE WICKS FIVE
WEEKS I ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY
SIX NINETY NINE GRAYSON PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BAUER-KAHAN KALRA. OBERNOLTE
WICKS WICKS ARE. ITEM NUMBER
THREE WE JUST DID IT- THAT'S
EIGHTY NINE OH FOR- LET'S CALL
THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BAUER-KAHAN.
KALRA GALLAGHER. GALLAGHER I.
OBERNOLTE WICKS BOOKS ARE.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN FOR
THE NEXT FEW MINUTES
. OKAY A
SATA AT THE TOP. THE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB FOR NINETY NINE
MAYES PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BAUER-KAHAN QUE HAN
KALRA. KALRA I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE HI ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SIX NINETY NINE GRAYSON PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS BAUER
CAN CAN I KALRA. KALRA I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE I. ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHTY NINE FOR
CHILD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN
I KALRA KALRA AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE AND FINALLY ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS BACKING HIM.
BAUER-KAHAN I KALRA. KALRA I
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE HI THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS AND STAFF.
MEETING ADJOURNED